The Joe Rogan Experience is Russia is
Russia considered Communists yeah still
I mean Russia don't they don't they
don't because wait dictatorship wait the
Soviet actually no let me say that let
me say that right I'm wrong no they have
elections
[Laughter]
the whole but if you want to run against
Putin bro yeah good luck yeah good luck
good luck with all that you ain't got
much time when was the last time they
had an election well you know that guy
pogosian who tried to make a coup
against uh Putin and he just died in a
plane crash is that that coup that
lasted like six hours the guy who like
they were literally headed towards
Moscow he was the head of the Wagner
group headed towards Moscow and then
they pulled back at the last minute yeah
and and Putin's like yeah bro I'll see
you in a little bit and his plane blew
up in the sky there's a video of his
plane in the sky and it's like on Fire
in the Sky yeah nothing suspicious about
that yeah yeah
I mean it's kind of crazy but like
Soviet Union was Communists and then the
Soviet Union fell like the history of
the Soviet Union and today's Russia is
really confusing to me like I don't I
don't know what to believe I don't know
what to believe with anything like when
in regards to history like man it's just
like what is real and what's not I'm
just like [__] I just like okay let's
just see how everything plays out but
Soviet Union fell so I thought like
Russia is claiming like uh Democratic
Socialism or something sort of
democratic
but who is basically running it because
Putin was the president of Russia or
whatever you know whatever they call it
over there and then he stepped down and
then his main guy took over and then
Putin's like [__] this I'm taking over
again and now he's running it and he's
been running
Russia
was it when did he start running when
was his second term as the President of
Russia
I have no you know who also has a
[__] uh Soviet passport or Russian
passport Roy Jones
really Roy Jones Jr's tight with Putin
interesting yeah well he's a star over
there man really yeah man he had a bunch
of boxing fights over there they love
him over there they love like you know
Elite Combat Sports athletes and
Roy Jones Jr and his prime was the
[__] man yeah when you talk about the
all-time greats you can in his prime he
may I would say he's the best technician
ever one of the best athletes that's
ever competed in boxing he's so fast
think about that one round he had with
uh Vinnie pazienza where the only round
coffee box history yeah and copy box
history where Vinnie pazienza couldn't
land a punch incredible incredible and
then Roy tried to stop the fight
he was teeing off on him he said the
referee come on man it's over yeah the
referee's like continue he's like all
righty
okay Putin has been Russia's most
powerful politician since he assumed the
presidency in 2000
um after resignation of his predecessor
Boris Yeltsin and but he stepped down
for a while and then came back again
though but he was like still kind of in
power if he still remains in power in
until 2036 his tenure will surpass even
that of Joseph Stalin who ruled the
Soviet Union for 29 years
stuff six year terms but he created a
new law that can allow that term limit
to reset it's a good move
if you want to run things that's what uh
Chris Rock was saying about uh Trump
when Trump made it into office like he's
never getting out of there he'll change
the [__] loss he's not gonna stop
being president
I remember Chris Rock was saying that on
stage it was hilarious you know that guy
Yuri besman off that you you bring up
every now and then and he explains
um ideological subversion right bro if
that shit's real and it seems like it's
real then does that mean Russia is
responsible for all our [__] if it's not
real what a prediction what a crazy
prediction that we would lose all faith
in our Democratic process and that we
would all the the children from the
universities will all adapt Marxist
leninist philosophy they all do yeah I
mean how many people are young kids they
consider themselves marxists yeah so are
we are we in the middle of a [__] of
of a Russian infiltration or is it
Chinese well I think both of those
countries are very clever you know they
they do some very clever things one of
the things that China does is they buy
up corporations do you know how many
someone showed me a list of all these
corporations that are run by China I
don't even know if this is true is is is
uh was it the Chinese president uh
is Gigi ping and
um
what's his [__] name from Russia uh
Putin Putin are they like buddies
because they're both like Communists
right well
um I'm confused there I'm sure they're
United against America now you know and
if Yuri besmanov if he's right
he's basically saying that Russia has
has put
we're under some kind of like 20-year
Russian infiltration ideological
subversion planners yeah what he's
basically saying was that they have this
very
long game approach whereas the United
States
we try to do things quickly and we think
about short term whereas in Russia they
think about things very long very long
yeah they also they're not a they don't
they're not afraid of people dying over
there because they lost so many people
in so many wars yeah I mean if it wasn't
for Russia Russia holding off the Nazis
Russia helped us win World War II in a
giant way in a [__] giant way and you
look at the losses that Russia faced
what was that
the one battle that Shane Gillis brought
up during the podcast like Shane Gillis
is a gigantic history buff and he
brought up this one battle where Russia
lost some [__] insane amount of
people holding off the the Nazis
I mean insane amount of people like way
more than any War we've ever lost that
was one of the things that people always
said about Russia
like the girls are so hot
and there's like they so outnumber men
because so many men died yeah so many
men died over there so for the longest
time I was like this over abundance of
these hot Russian women
and how many of them came over and
became spies yeah
man it's like
what the [__] is going on I don't know
what is going on it's like I don't know
what to believe anymore dog it's like it
almost seems like
there's a there's a Great Awakening and
there's a great reset you know Cloud
Schwab talking about the great reset
um and then there's a Great Awakening A
lot of people are waking up it's like
sometimes I feel like the Great
Awakening is winning and then sometimes
I feel like the great reset is winning
like when you start like all these
fighting that we're doing we're fighting
over like dumb [__] all the time like
all the time like bathrooms gender yeah
meanwhile like this new world order is
like uh like digital currency and
climate change yeah it's like what the
[__] is going on it just seems like it
seems like um
like like like there's our politicians
here you know the ones that we see the
ones that are on TV and then whatever's
above them the guys we don't see maybe
they just want to just destroy America
like how do we destroy America how do we
make it I think what they want is
control and they want control the way
that China has control the way that
Russia has control yeah and yeah there's
so much freedom in America in terms of
freedom of speech and freedom to do
whatever you want
it's like it's like uh like on the
surface we see the left fighting with
the right right on the surface right but
what if the overall goal is to get us
like the only way we're going to have
like a military regime like the
controllers they want as as much of a
military regime as possible maybe
disguise it so we don't think we're
under but the best way to do that the
most uh
not the easiest but the best ways you
got to make the people embrace the
military right you got to make them
Embrace how do you make them embrace it
right now we're kind of embracing it
we're like oh where's the military
tribunals and all that [__] with all the
[__] it's almost like that like were we
tricked are we being tricked into
embracing the military like there's so
like I don't know which way the shit's
going it's just so all over the [__]
place man there's like all the stuff
that Biden is doing it's like
it's like
who who's advising this [__] you
know what I'm just running again
and then they're talking about they're
talking about Michelle Obama running
that keeps coming up